Sandman should Harvey Weinstein there's
all this stuff happen in Hollywood is
like it's not just him but this like
this crazy effect of all of these people
being outed and coming like did you see
that's type of stuff at all or do you
not notice any of it like well this that
that predecessor that was happening in
Hollywood like we were you able to see
any of that or is it just not that
apparent even when you're there a lot ah
no I'm not really part I'm not there I I
don't know I didn't really see it but I
assume I assume it goes on because it
goes on everywhere so it's you know but
now I haven't got any um I haven't got
any oh I knew because I saw there's all
that no I you know I you know I go there
twice a year but for the Emmys and the
Golden Globes and but now I've and you
know obviously I'm not a young
vulnerable woman you know so I it's
there's a reason why I'm probably
encountered it I'm amazed by the petal
[ __ ] more than what the pedo stuff that
they talked about like there's all these
all these people that like these
underground pedophilia like the sexual
right now man's been talking about yeah
for years and people laughed at him
people after Corey Feldman Barbara
Walters you're hurting a whole industry
not to be fair they were laughing at
everything else Corey Feldman was doing
its tufted that's a very good example so
the first somebody the Golden Globes
I did feel there or you shouldn't make
fun of these wonderful people and I just
thought [ __ ] that what you're talking
about I should make the richest most
beautiful privileged people in the world
I shouldn't tease them about yes I
should right I'm playing the court
jester I'm playing low status here I'm
I'm sticking it to NBC and the Golden
Globes and all the people who are being
honored and you know I'm playing the fat
guy at home so of course I've got to
write um and evil at last year I did a
joke what was that film spotlight uh-huh
I said spotlight great acclaim some said
exposure to I was Polanski calls it his
favorite date movie and there was over
you to take criticized I when I did the
joke about Mel Gibson I like a drink as
much the next man less than next man is
Mel Gibson there was some comedian going
or Mel Gibson's a better director
Makeda boys well wasn't ever go he's
directing he's a great director
yep no that's not the bother joke Mel
Gibson wasn't able to come back he with
a better joke yes and I've got nothing
against Mel games and he's never abused
me here I mean but but what I mustn't
mention you know and I kept it light and
polite right you know the thing that we
all know when we find out what did I go
for I went and a little bit about him
getting drunk and saying an anti-semitic
thing right right I could have gone
deeper as good of things that I would
have Mel Gibson drinking is like the
least of and again I dunno macam and
when he's down and go but it was just a
joke it was just fun you know I didn't I
wasn't trying to I wasn't even trying to
expose or bring down but the oh I
shouldn't go there why shouldn't you go
there so fraternity mentality I think
where they're all just trying to kind of
cover everything up protect your own
until it's over and then you're out well
that's why there's Morgan you know
whatever you think it was Morgan
sometimes he gets it right and did a big
article with all these people going how
disgusting it is what everyone's saying
yes he's a month so he should be kicked
out of it and he should obviously but
then they're then they're given Polanski
or standing ovations right well come on
where's the [ __ ] let's keep it a new
girl just came out and said that he he
molest her when she was 10 porno me this
other girl yeah and the problem here's
why I don't like him made fun of because
when you do that it kind of shames them
over how funny they are by protecting
him it's almost like if you make fun of
Roman Polanski they all have to
acknowledge oh that's right he did [ __ ]
a 13 year old and we all know it and we
still lined up to work with him right
but if a guy has you know said something
racist we'll will ban him from the club
it depends what it is but it is Israeli
iftar how loved he is how important he
was how good his work was how recent the
thing is since the work was it during it
before Patrice's bit about Michael
Jackson mm-hmm about um can I can i
still listen to thriller maybe he wasn't
doing bad I don't care about but can I
still listen to thriller and people do
make those little
decisions in their head I wonder all the
time like we see photos of the biggest
pop star in the world 'rihanna and she's
just been beaten unmercifully about the
face and then within a year it's like oh
my god did you hear the new Chris Brown
song it's terrific I don't get it why
don't I I don't get up people that have
short memories in the hypocrisy and it's
yeah